(logo whooshing, squeaking)
(bright electronic music)
- All right, I am
with my mom, for this video,
I am gonna dress my mom in
my generation's clothing trend.
Are you excited?
- Yeah.
(both chuckling)
- How do you describe
your style?
- What colors do you like
to wear?
- But also, sometimes
she wears a lot of patterns.
She's a very smart
shopper, she uses coupons.
She goes on holiday sales with my aunt.
Well, today, we are going to H&M.
- What's cool is that
I've never seen my mom
in these clothes ever before,
what do you think our family
members will say?
(laughs)
- So we're gonna go shop and
she's gonna wear the clothes
Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday
and we're gonna get reactions
from all our family members
and all her friends, she'll be stylin'.
(upbeat music)
It threw me back to when I
was younger and I was shopping
with my mom, shopped for four hours.
My mom kept trying to control
what I was choosing for her
so I had to separate her to the other side
of the store so I could shop in comfort
and I got to play with
so many different colors
and textures that I've
never seen my mom in,
covered everything that I wanted.
I'm so happy with my choices for her.
I got this leather jacket for her.
I have never seen her wear
leather my whole life.
Leather just calls out badass,
which is how I see my mom.
This is a power jacket,
especially with a gold chain
and the purse, badass yet fancy.
Heading out to like a girls' night out,
ready to beat up some people at a bar,
a don't-mess-with-me
jacket, what, what, what?
Mom, you look 40.
- We're about to go out
and see what people think.
My mom's used to wearing,
what, one-inch heels
and this one's 2 1/2, she
originally thought it was
eight inches (chuckles).
(chuckles)
What do you think--
(laughs)
of mom's outfit?
- Doesn't she look like she could
kick butt?
- This coat I got because
I love the giant collar,
just called old-fashioned,
something Anna Wintour
would wear, super comfy,
perfect for a colder day.
Everything is so giant except the sleeves,
which shows that it is meant
to be that big (chuckles).
When you walk into someone's
house, they're like,
"Can I can have your
coat," and you're like,
yeah, I got a coat like the
CEO of a Fortune 500 company.
I love different angles of
the bottom, sharp corners,
Fashion Week-type coat.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Well, I chose this because
it's pink, it's loose
so it's comfortable,
the buttons on the side
add a little bit of flair, cute flat,
also millennial pink, super girly
but age appropriate, pants is slender.
I like that you can see the buttons
on the pants with the top tucked in.
You look like you're about
to go to town, have a cosmo,
even though she doesn't drink,
maybe she'll have some tea.
She's gonna make all the
ladies in the neighborhood
jealous.
(laughing)
(bright music)
- I chose this outfit because
I love the poofy arms.
It looks very Gaga-esque,
the bows are very cool
and youthful and feminine.
I love the contrast between
the white and black and punch
of red, the purse is super
classy; I love the gold chains.
Pants are super slimming with the boots.
The boots are super hip; I
like that the gold buckle
matches the gold chain of the purse.
This whole look screens youth, fashion,
extravaganza, ready to go dancing
or shopping at some fancy store.
It's a very versatile look,
I think it's age appropriate,
yet hella youthful, she looks very tall.
Damn, so stylin'.
(chuckling)
- I chose this outfit because I wanted
a comfy casual look, chill, relax,
something around the house.
It's a thin coat, so that can be tossed on
whenever she want, like
a soft little blanket.
There's a lot of textures going on.
Studded letters on the sweater.
It says gray because this
this outfit is all gray,
yet it stands out, love
the boots, Ugg-like.
My mom likes to go on
walks, so this is perfect
for that winter cool chill weather,
modern with a touch of comfort, hip, free,
relaxed, all these words come to mind.
This is perfect for
sitting around watching
Vietnamese television, watching (mumbles),
going to visit relatives.
- Look at this comfy outfit,
this is like we're going
shopping on a winter's day,
drinking a Starbucks.
- What was your favorite
outfit?
- Which one would you wear again?
- My favorite outfit
for her was definitely
the white poofy one, that one
was very classy and special
and unique, when you see
it far away, you're like,
whoa, it's so nice.
- I think you're strong,
that's why it fits very well.
I had such a good
experience, I'm so glad I got
to finally see my mom in different types
of clothes, I've always wondered
about what would she look
like and now I got to see it, thank you
for doing it.
- Yeah (chuckles).
(upbeat electronic music)
(logo whooshing, squeaking)
- Okay, all right.
- That's all, bye-bye.
- Bye-bye.